[Music]
welcome to chest fur nights I'm back so
you're excited at home calmed down a
little bit I just talked to one o'clock
class so I had to go to Starbucks and
get some medicine and get some sparkling
water and I forgot all my gun jokes
that's how scary that class was okay now
we'll do half an hour of Donald jokes
all right
so in my last class one of the kids did
it I'm truck without knowing it yeah it
was you he had pawns on h2g2 f2 and then
c2 b2 a2 and he had Knights on e 2 in d2
and said that's my wall so there you go
okay now this class we're going to
discuss something you should already
know except you don't know it that's why
I'm going to teach you okay no talking
let's see new position I can't do that I
have to do this and keep click up
classes over okay now as you all know
we'll clear the board and we'll yeah
okay there's a grandmaster you never
heard of called Roman ginger Hashmi Lee
okay and he has a funny bet about this
position which will pop up momentarily
there we go you with who's heard of him
okay now let's vote because voting's fun
okay just don't vote for this time you
can vote for white should win if both
sides play correctly or black should
draw if both sides play correctly and
just if to look over there looking at me
I could help who says White's winning
raise your hand who says now black
should draw many people voted twice and
I'm not kidding to the people at home at
least half of them voted twice so their
staff right I guess I don't know
okay sort of like in the real election
they voted twice okay so especially in
Michigan was confident Lee all right can
I help you all right did you vote for
Buchanan again alright the reason we're
talking about this is this is a draw but
you don't know
that large larger does the other one
just randomly raise their hand that was
good now the reason it's a draw is the
bishop is on a white square and
therefore will always be on a white
square the or you could go to the black
square okay and the black King which is
stopping the pawn from promoting is on a
dark square if this Bishop was on a dark
square white would win easily but now
you don't win and the reason you don't
win is you can't kick him out of the
corner and if you permanently put them
in the corner it'll be stalemate and
even though Nigel short doesn't like it
still made as a draw okay this is
stalemate if you don't know what still
need is go to the one o'clock class
although you will never learn what it is
then so then it's not going to help you
or you could play Bishop d5 stalemate if
you prefer that stalemate
if you don't still me then I'm going to
go here and here and here forever you
could stop that by going there and then
you'd lose your pawn or I could not take
the pawn and still draw okay so this is
a draw any professional chess player and
even the cameraman knows it you believe
that Bensimon does this is a draw now
the reason I brought up Roman Jinja
house really is he goes to a tournament
and he says hey if I'm white here
I can promote my pawn to a queen and
professional players like myself we know
that this is a draw so we're like
alright let's see you do it now remember
he didn't say he could win he said he
could promote his pot into a queen so
what he does is he promotes his ball
into a queen do to do and then he says
you have to pay me because I promoted by
pawn to a queen of course you don't win
because you could just take it but he
didn't he didn't he didn't say he would
win he say promote his pawn in a queen
okay now this is a draw but there's a
reason why it's a draw it's a draw
because blacks King is on h8
if blacks King was over here on the
other side of the board then white would
get a queen and some of
can mate with a queen some of you okay
yeah some of the kids are nodding it
somewhere like yeah yeah and most of
them are lying so even the ones that are
sitting all right now why am i showing
you this
because I have to kill time until the
class ends so let's do that now okay
good let's go to the actual lecture
where we discuss this in detail why
because it keeps happening it keeps
happening okay
now this is a famous puzzle that I've
shown people for the last 20 years and
it was invented by CM lloyd in the 1800s
it's an old puzzle now if you remember
the last problem that was about 1 minute
ago
there was a black king and he was in H a
and I was explaining when the Kings in
the corner it's a draw and in this
position the king is not in the corner
so it might be a drop maybe black he'll
get his King to the corner ok but if
you're white you don't want blacks king
to get to the corner and then maybe
you'll win this is actually a winning
position for white if white plays
perfect every move or better than
perfect arjen's never seen this position
what very good he said he has but he
forgot okay you with the wrong answer
Knight very good did you get that did
you get the knife now you're incorrect
again just like you were last class
because I said the wrong answer you give
the right answer you keep making me look
bad can you edit that out where he's
right because I said the wrong answer
Bishop e6 the only winning move now if
black saunters over to the corner then
he doesn't get there too good does he
now he has to move away because that's
the rules and then white Queens there
for King f8 it's not a good move so
let's play King e7 let's play a good
move now what do you do one move that
wins
you with an answer I'm not going to I'm
leaving a guess anymore
keep moving your palm which you haven't
moved yet I like that but keep moving it
yeah aged six right now this is sort of
a threat so probably black should stop
that you now this is sort of a threat so
we should probably stop that you this
ship f5 now black has lots of King moves
I would guess
five and four well g7 is illegal
four of them let the pawn queen so
probably those aren't good so let's not
let the pawn Queen now black wants to
play King here and finally we have our
draw I wonder if we can stop King GA
hold on a bathrooms Dover there you
he's good at killing time good job the
problem with this should be six is I go
here and then you're like oh say oh now
when I taught that to Beck he said
otally and I'm like close enough
wait none of you got that and only your
home got that either
all right well Spencer got if he's
watching but he's not watching you yeah
the one with the right answer
Bishop eight seven and now all the
squares that go to the H file are
prevented from you know going there and
if King f6 with the idea of num yum-yum
we can stop King g5 by playing yeah king
f4 and white wins so that's a puzzle and
that's the answer and that kind of
Bishop and wrong colored rook pawn
puzzle that's fun but in the real world
where we're playing chess that never
happens
except it happened every game the last
week that's that's all that happened
okay
so I'm doing a lecture on it now I
played in a tournament ten days ago at
the Chess Club upstairs and I played Naz
epoch easy she's the US Women's Champion
okay and I got a winning position this
one I'm up two pawns because I said so
also I'm up two pawns and here i
blundered a bishop because that's how I
roll I played rugby for and she took my
bishop it's true if I take her rook
which I did do then she checks and wins
my rook yeah you see it
so I thought I could take with a queen
but she sew ins my rook because of
Bishop c5 okay so Rick d4 was a really
bad move okay so then we get to the end
of the game I guess I have to leave and
come back because that's what I do
okay well let's let's find out we get to
the end of the game
notice she still up a bishop now most of
you would take the bishop and then black
would play f2 that f1 so then I would
lose so I didn't do that
I played king d2 and in this position
she made the move that doesn't win it
ended in a draw
she played Bishop f6 I played here and
we agreed to a draw
notice this pawns queening on a white
square and that's a dark squared bishop
as we've been discussing throughout this
class that's a draw okay now in this
position black could have won by getting
to that position we just looked at in
the puzzle black could have taken then
defended her pawn now I thought I'll do
this she'll take my queen I'll take her
pawn and she has the wrong rook pawn we
both thought that so we thought it was a
draw however she can get to that puzzle
position by playing H 4 H 3 and now if
you remember the puzzle and the answer
that Arjun gave two minutes ago how does
black win here Arjun told you two
minutes ago
we already saw this position you
Bishop h2o now the White King can't get
over there can it and if I play King
here just like in the puzzle although
here it's easier the king has lots of
squares to go to that's King g4 now
neither one of us saw the idea of Bishop
G 3 H 4 H 3 Bishop H 2 because we had
seconds on our clock just like when you
play chess our game was five and a half
hours long and we both had about 20
seconds left so we didn't play the
perfect moves although sort of did until
the end ok so that game ended in a draw
I should have won then she should have
won that it was a draw ok and I was like
wow this ship in the wrong colored rook
pawn I'll never see that again and then
in the same tournament we had bishop and
wrong rook line okay in this position
white has to passed pawns and what he
did was he got black's bishop by
sacrificing one pawn and then winning
the bishop for the other pawn first he
moved around for 100 moves to kill time
because he will my lecture to last very
long okay he's good at killing time and
finally he decided to win the bishop c7
check which way does black take with the
king of the bishop if you take with the
bishop I'll play e7 check and EA queen
fitted with a king and they got bishop
and the bishops on a white square and
this pawns on a dark square is the black
King in the corner no this is a drawn
position if both sides play well however
I said if both sides play well if you
want to see not playing well this is a
good example of that every move was the
worst okay I'm leaving playing okay now
in the game what should what should
happen is white should try to take this
pawn at some point and while he's doing
that blacks running into the corner in
instead they moved around forever
putting us to sleep okay
and white missed several ways to win
when blacks King was too far away okay
the first one was in this position this
position white could play Bishop g8
Bishop h7 forcing the King this way and
what happens is if I take your pawn and
your king is on this side you can't stop
me from Queen and can you and that's
what should have happened okay and and
white wins White's going to play King g5
and then make a queen the black King
can't get over there can it okay but he
played king d3 instead he's still
winning and this position he could have
played King g4 and one the same way and
the black King can't get to h8 because
of the white bishop and the white king
the King can't get into the corner and
white wins instead he played here now
the game ended in a way that will
confuse most of you because you're
easily confused I'm talking to you at
home of course okay in this position
black claim to draw he said it's a draw
and the director was my comer and said
why is it a draw you with the right
answer the 50 mover rule the rule you
don't understand I'll explain it now
that 1 minute after I explanation you
cannot understand it again okay
in chess if both sides make 50 moves in
a row 50 and there's no captures and
there's no pawn moves you can claim a
draw that's actually what just happened
if why did play King takes pawn that
would be a capture then they have to
play 50 more moves
this game was 162 moves it would have
been over 200 lose if you'd play King
takes pawn now in this position if both
sides keep playing and don't claim a
draw Black's King does get to ha8 you
see what I'm saying and therefore what
should the result be
to draw so in the final position it
should be a draw but he claimed to draw
and that game went over 7 hours and 162
movies plus tax with no tax okay so that
was a long game so I was like wow I had
bishop and wrong rook pawn and my
opponent didn't win and they should have
and then in another game in the same
tournament there was bishop and wrong
rook pawn and the guy should have won
and he didn't that'll never happen again
and then the following week in the world
championship match between and the other
guy Sergey Karjakin he came from Detroit
we was doing some carjacking right yeah
they played a game and car yakin was in
a lot of trouble ok but he knew about
the famous games of Ben Feingold and
Matt Larsen now in this position white
had good winning chances White's king is
better and to bishops is better than a
rug and white actually had three pawns
and he gave one of his pawns away and
white wants to play like bishop here and
Bishop takes pawn but he's in check so
that would be illegal so he blocked with
a bishop and then car Yaakov was like
wait a minute
bishop and wrong rook pawn you can be
down a bishop and a pawn and still draw
and he was like let's see this rook pawn
is going to a dark square right so which
bishop does Kotkin want to take the red
one or the green one wants to take the
green one
however you may have noticed white also
has a jeep line white doesn't just have
an H point so car yakin was like let's
get rid of that Jeep on H five
blundering upon what a pot sir and
Carlson is like oh boy a free pawn and
then Kyle Atkins like I have an idea
let's make a queen and Carlsen's like
ish don't think so BAM and cariocans
like I'm the worst player in the world
let's give more pieces away okay so car
yakin gave everything away just like you
guys do and now we have bishop and wrong
rook pawn these rook pawns they don't go
to the Queenie square of the bishop so
karyakin must have seen all the recent
developments on this endgame and
sacrificed everything and he's like wow
I know how to play King g8 King h8 I
know how to do that and so he did and
then Magnus is like aha you can't play
King g8 okay it's not still me because
he has a pawn now what's funny is if
this pawn was gone it's an easy easy
easy draw but when there's a pawn on the
board
sometimes you unseal mates yourself and
the guy gets rid of his rip ones but not
here you with the right answer right
every legal move draws g6 and g5 that's
why you're the instrument right however
he played g5 but g6 also draws and now
you could take the punt on passant
unless you're in the one o'clock class
then you don't know what that is or you
can take it extra-crispy I mean regular
H takes G stalemate or H takes G
stalemate he took on passant
and it was stalemate who won nobody so
car yeah can give everything away to get
Bishop and wrong rook line now I want to
explain something to you when computers
came out I tried to trick them okay you
can't trick them now well sometimes you
can so I would set up a position like
this I would set it up right there's a
prize for shutting the door
they're looking at the door like wow
that's hmm okay now when computers were
getting very popular in the 80s and 90s
I set this position up and the computer
said whites plus five billion because
whites up of Bishop and five pawns but
this is a draw as we discussed earlier
because black plays King here King here
if I put this on a computer now it's
going to say it's a draw because it can
calculate a thousand moves ahead and
they can't do anything okay so
grandmasters know these positions are
drawers so sometimes when they're losing
even though they're down a bishop and a
pawn or a bishop and two pawns or a
bishop and five pawns you can still draw
because the wrong collar drip one you
can escape to these positions that's
what I did I should have lost what I
drew that's what Matt Larson did he
should have drawn then he should have
lost then he drew that's what car yakin
did and he did draw that was correct
for some reason the best players in the
world play better than me and Matt
Larson how way that actually makes sense
yeah okay so it's not always a draw as
we saw in the puzzle and in the games
but it has good drawing chances and it's
always a draw with your kings in the
corner blocking the pawns okay you can't
you can't win these positions and these
are important things to know when you're
losing in an endgame let's say you're
playing an endgame and you're down a
piece so you're like wow I'm going to
lose well if there's no pawns on the
board you're not going to lose if your
opponent has a king and a bishop and you
have a king you're not going to lose if
your opponent has a lot of pawns you
will so when you're down material or
you're losing you try to escape to these
known positions that are draws that way
you don't lose and even though that's
what me and Larson had in mind we were
still losing that's what Corey Aachen
had in mind and he did it
that's what samlloyd had in mind in his
puzzle but he found the one way for
white to win the puzzle that I showed
you at the beginning you guys remember
they're right this one everybody thinks
it's a draw but it's only a draw when
you're King
here as Matt Larsen found out okay and
if your bishop gets here and your pawn
gets here as in the puzzle and is in my
game with knives epoch easy which didn't
happen but it could have then then why
twins it's only a draw if your King can
stop the pawn from promoting if your
king is not in the corner then it's not
so easy and in fact this happens more
often than you think because
grandmasters are good at defense when
they're losing or about to lose they try
to find some tricky draw where it looks
like they're losing but they have a
trick at the end now to finish I'll show
you an unrelated position to show you
what I mean this is a well known drawn
position where it looks like you're
winning
so I guess it's black to move okay now
again I was making fun earlier people
might have heard at home or maybe you
guys were asleep when the video started
there's a grandmaster named Nigel short
who likes to say crazy things okay and
some of the things he says aren't crazy
but that's an accident okay and he says
still maid should be a win if I still
meet you I should win you can't move I
should win but in still me it's a draw
now if you who plays checkers if you
play checkers and you still meet your
opponent you do in well that's chess
okay so it's possible yeah also possible
okay now Nigel thinks stalemate should
be a win I actually like that to draw
because then funny stuff can happen
otherwise nothing's funny now this
position is a draw because of the
stalemate rule and if it was White's
turn to move white would win but it's
blacks turn to move because I said so
okay now you'll notice it's check unless
for the one o'clock class then you won't
even know you're playing chess all right
now if the King goes to the F file at
any given moment about now then you lose
your queen so your King can never go to
F file never and if your King goes back
and forth even though both people will
start laughing right isn't that funny
okay you still won't win if you want to
win you've got to move your king up the
board and avoid the F file because they
won't get pinned then and in this
position it looks like black is finished
now if you play check I'll checkmate you
but because of the drawing trickiness of
the class being down a lot of material
but drawing anyway black hasn't moved
and the game should be a draw white
can't win Black has a very sneaky move
and if you saw every movie ever made
you'll know not to underestimate the
sneaky you know movie that is you rook
h6 check that's also called
a skewer see how you're doing all that
there the only move that makes any sense
is taking it and that's stalemate so
it's a draw
unless you're playing Nigel that you
might go to the director and you might
say that he wins now in Nigel's world
where you win if you still meet your
opponent in his world you could actually
win with just a king okay in fact I'm
going to go on Twitter and or Facebook I
haven't decided yet and I'm going to ask
Nigel and I'll tell you guys next week
I'm going to ask them I'm going to say
now wait a minute Nigel let me ask you a
question in this position if white plays
h7 a7 if you play king c7 does black win
black still needed white in his world he
says if you still need somebody you
should win so you could win with just
the king I don't know he might say no no
just the king is a draw otherwise you I
don't know he's gonna say he might write
like ten paragraphs I yeah yeah I'll say
if you want with a steal maybe what if
you have a king he's still in
it'll be like of course he'll say of
course not
well I actually like this tell me to
draw because then when somebody's
destroying you you can still draw
otherwise you can well your opponent has
a queen a rook a bishop you have a king
and that's it
you can still draw with this deal mate
rule otherwise see that's the problem
Nigel's a little older than he used to
be and not sure how
maybe he got older and so when Nigel's
up a queen and a rook he's always still
meeting his opponent he doesn't win
anymore
he's got to stop doing that half the
kids every kid believes me you guys at
home they're like yeah yeah yeah they're
the smartest kids ever all right
so I hope you learned something today
mainly about the budget okay and also
don't call Taiwan they'll call you
[Music]
you
[Music]